[Music]  eg can't confirm kirsten dunst is  engaged to her fargo co-star Jesse  Plemons well can you hurry up yeah I  still got a my takes time grand in a  hole no I know I I just miss yourself  Jesse reportedly popped the question  over Golden Globes weekend after about  nine months of dating the couple was  first spotted getting cozy running  errands together in Los Angeles last May  that's just a month after Kirsten called  things off with her longtime boyfriend  actor Garrett Hedlund kind of need to  buy that now the engagement is just the  latest exciting news for the actress any  chance for more television I would love  to if the opportunity presented itself  again yeah of course yeah the best it  was revealed this week that she's  working on a new dark comedy series for  MC  [Music]  you